you might know we're in the middle of uh
drew's news or starting
and obviously i'm here with the lovely
little dreamboat
my partner in crime russell yeah hi and
matchy matchy again
i know i did say i cheated this morning
though i said what color is drew wearing
and then i chose pink
well i think our pinks are so
complementary yeah but it's like you
were just talking about with paint color
color
color makes you feel different right so
high cherry
well and in design you can look at
something and be like
it doesn't work you change the color and
all of a sudden poof it's the greatest
thing you've ever seen
when anna said that to me at our flower
home brands
it just was a light bulb aha moment for
me in design
because it's so true color changes
everything yeah and it can be affordable
i don't want to brag but i got this at
the burbank mall for 16.99 so thank you
well and it looks like there's a lot of
effort going on in that knitting
thank you thanks it doesn't look like
your average
garden-variety boring sweater that
thing's got detail yeah thanks and i had
to shrink it because i lost weight isn't
that fun
i know i put it in the dryer which you
never do with a sweater but yeah
i have a pair of pants with a bra strap
that's been uh
set in there and every day like it's
getting a little
like i'm i'm going to get rid of the bra
straps i understood
speaking of bra straps
what a transition well basically
it's like the corsets is what like led
me to it and brazier's
and the whole thing the whole world
bridgerton ross okay you promised me you
were gonna watch it
yeah last week if you were watching this
program i told you i hadn't really
started bridgerton so i said this
weekend this last weekend i was going to
get into it
and girl did i get into it you told me
you had an awakening
if you will i did i i was like i'm not
dead yeah it is okay it's a really sweet
show
until about episode um five and then
it's a real
sexy show i was watching it and
right oh yeah that's like my aunt said
she watched it with my grandma which i
cannot believe
let me these people are so for starters
the the whole
show is gorgeous right the way it's
shiny it's really beautiful and i was
actually just reading a piece from
um the production designer that he
stayed up at night over the tone
of blue in the parlor room at the
bridgerton's house and i have to say
it's like one of my favorite sets in the
whole show my favorite room in the whole
world
it's a perfect powder gray periwinkle
it's
oh if you guys aren't watching the show
it's on netflix you need to because drew
told me it was
so good and you did not lie and can i
just talk quickly about the the people
um the the main woman and the the main
man
yeah so she is like a living breathing
disney princess she's ready
yes yes guess what what ross
and everybody they're gonna be here on
friday
no are they gonna they're going to be
here on friday
i have basically stalked them i'm such a
fan of the show and
what i love about it is not only is it
just masterful
yes and we talked about shonda rhimes
and netflix and what kind of show
they're presenting and it just is so
responsible and beautiful and perfect is
that it's giving people joy
and there's a lot going on in the world
right now and when you can escape and
entertain
people it's like i mean it's a
phenomenon for business with netflix
people are watching this and they're
getting a lot out of it yeah and okay
mostly
can i meet them when they're here on
friday yeah you're gonna be here oh my
god
we're meeting them together okay i'm
gonna what am i gonna wear that's all i
can think about now what am i gonna do
so check this out um women and home
reports that actually people are so
crazy about bridgerton that they're
starting to dress
like bridgerton it's a new fashion trend
called
regency core and sales are up on corsets
on pure dresses
pearl and feather headbands and even
elbow length
gloves are selling out like hot cakes
well like i went out and look how
gorgeous these costumes are whoever
uh designed all this is going to win a
lot of awards for this show yeah and
they should
and i keep thinking it's funny that this
is now a trend because i watch it and
i'm thinking
could i pull off an ascot like is that a
thing ross we actually did that sketch
at christmas time where you had like the
jaw furs and the boots and the coat
yeah like you went super like you can
pull that
off maybe i'll do an ascot for them on
friday hmm let's do it
uh all right all right dress the part uh
well from the regency era to the modern
times you know i love a steamy romance
not just bridgeton
people magazine is reporting the sexiest
man alive michael b jordan
is officially off the market i know
we're all just
right we're all sad about it but come on
they found love i know
we should be happy but we're really gone
and look what a gorgeous couple that is
uh
lori harvey who bt dubs is steve
harvey's
daughter i just learned that me too the
two confirmed that they're
together by doing what people do now
when they announce that
they're together they become instagram
official that's the thing people do
i can't help it the whole instagram
official
like thing and the zeitgeist
you know i i don't i i just got to get
used to it it's like
people probably felt like when call
waiting entered the picture they were
like what is that
what is call waiting star 69 i feel that
way about
instagram official like i'm just i'm a
little irritated by the term i'm not on
board yet but i think i've just got to
get on it because it's it's like
it's what's happening well you have to
get on board with it because when
when you're in a new relationship you're
going to have to make that call
yeah you're gonna go i-g-o-f i know
which i just
by the way by the way igof i that's
let's ch
i'm changing it to that igos yeah well
because
you know i've been in a relationship
almost a year now right have you made it
igos
no not yet because he's like a real
person as opposed to me but you know
what i mean he like has a job and a
like a professional thing and so it's
like this it's a weird moment like when
do you do that and everybody's
opinions are up in your very personal
life well we had talked about like
olivia wilde and harry styles something
you know that's
i i feel for people um in the public eye
uh because i have been in it myself and
i see it
you know objectively as well i think at
least i try to
sometimes you want to let people kind of
figure it out before
society goes you're together and you're
like god i'm just still getting to know
this person that's too much pressure
it almost can make people run away from
it because the outside pressure starts
to like
you know so i do think that igof is a
great way to take control of the
situation and say
i'm ready to put this out there rather
than you dictating
um what hasn't actually even really in
reality
happened yet we're still figuring this
out ourselves so
maybe i've turned a corner on igof
especially now that it has a pithy new
name thanks to you you're welcome and i
have a question for you drew
what could we take a picture and post it
today and we can become
igof oh my god omg we're igoffing
omg
[Music]
i love this all right really quickly we
have a beautiful
story to go to commercial break on from
cnn an oncologist
in pine bluff arkansas is closing his
practice after a 29
years of being there and as a parting
gift
he's erasing all the debts of his cancer
patients it's extraordinary that he's
doing this
dr omar atik wiped away
650 000
in bills for his patients he worked with
the billing company
and he literally eradicated
the funds that people who are going
through such traumatic things in their
life
he was able to take this out and
have them not have to worry about that
part of it it's such a burden you know
my i've lost both my parents to cancer
and while they were going through it
they did think about the financial uh
burden that it would bring i'll bring on
to us
and and the idea that people who are
literally fighting for their lives could
be could have that relief
is an extraordinary thing that this
doctor did so thank you
thank you thank you for doing that i i
just was blown away by that story
i'm in that beautiful story too thank
you
it just reminds us in a time when maybe
it doesn't feel like there's like
goodness out there
there is goodness everywhere so thank
you doctor thank you for doing that
and thank you for bringing all that good
news
you know for all of us here on this
news program because that's really what
it's all about i just love you and we're
[Music]
ogif